- [Instructor] Hinduism is often known
for its large and
complex pantheon of gods.
The goal of this video is
to give an overview of them
and to think about how they are connected,
and how they are perceived.
So the Hindu Trinity,
as it is often called,
is made up of Shiva, Vishnu and Brahma.
They are often considered to be
the three most important gods.
In modern-day Hinduism,
Shiva and Vishnu have
far more followership,
I guess you can say,
or more people view Shiva or Vishnu
as the Supreme Being.
There's more temples
dedicated to Shiva and Vishnu
than there are too Brahma.
Followers of Shiva,
those who view him as the Supreme Being,
they're called Shaivas.
They're following Shaivism,
or sometimes referred to as Shivaism.
Shiva has multiple
aspects and as we'll see,
many of these gods have multiple aspects
and multiple connections,
but is often referred to as the Destroyer
or the Transformer.
Vishnu, as I've mentioned,
also has a significant following,
a significant chunk of
Hindus are Vaishnivas,
or followers of Vaishnavism or Vishnuism.
And Vishnu is considered the Preserver.
Brahma, as I mentioned,
does not have as much followership
in modern-day Hinduism,
but he is considered to be the Creator.
Now in some narratives,
he is the Creator and in other narratives,
he has been created by
either Shiva or Vishnu.
Now Brahma should not be
confused with Brahman,
that we talked about in previous videos.
Brahman is considered
the absolute reality.
the true nature of things.
And Brahma you could
view as an aspect of it.
It is one God as part of
this true nature of things.
In fact, everything you see on this video,
in fact everything you see in reality,
all of these gods to a Hindu
could be considered as just
aspects of the true God
or the true reality of Brahman.
Now what's interesting in Hinduism
is that gods are not viewed
to have a strict gender.
For example, Vishnu has
a female incarnation
and there's also groups of Hindus
who view God as taking a
fundamentally female form.
One group are known as
the followers of Shaktism.
To Shaktism, God is female,
the supreme goddess and takes many forms.
Parvati as you see listed here
is referred to the Divine Mother.
She's viewed as Shiva's
consort or Shiva's wife,
but she has other forms like Durga
which is used as a stronger,
more aggressive form of Parvati,
sometimes referred to as Devi or Shakti.
Shakti means strength or power
and is a warrior goddess.
You have Lakshmi who
is the wife of Vishnu,
who represents or has aspects
of wealth and prosperity.
You have Saraswati who has aspects
of knowledge, music and the arts
and is viewed as the consort
or the wife of Brahma.
Now these are some of
the principal deities
that we have on this top row,
but there's also many, many
other significant deities.
And as we will see,
depending on what part of India you're in
and which group subsect
of Hinduism you meet,
they will place different
levels of emphasis
on different deities
and have different traditions
and different rituals.
So Ganesh who is very recognizable
because he has an elephant head,
he is often referred to as Ganpati.
He is viewed as the son
of Shiva and Parvati.
There's a great story about how he,
why he has this elephant head.
He is viewed as the god of new beginnings
and the remover of obstacles.
He has a lot of followership
and he is revered
in a lot of regions of western India,
and that's not the only places,
but he is known to be a principal God
in some of these regions.
Durga similarly, that I referred to,
in eastern India, especially Bengal,
the place where my family comes from,
Durga Puja, the Puja for Durga,
the rituals for Durga are considered to be
a very the important part
of the Hindu religion.
If you go into the south,
for some Hindus,
Karthikeya or also known as Murugan,
might be a significant deity.
That is the god of war.
Vishnu is known to have
multiple incarnations
that are very prominent.
The most prominent of which are Rama,
Vishnu's seventh incarnation.
He is the main protagonist in the Ramayan,
the famous Hindu epic.
You have Krishna, who is
Vishnu's eighth incarnation.
And he is a significant
figure throughout Hinduism,
including the Mahabharata
and the subset of the Mahabharata,
which is the Bhagavad Gita.
Now what's really interesting,
and I already alluded to it,
is you have all of this
diversity in Hinduism.
Someone who worships Shiva,
you might see at a superficial level,
seems more different in their
rituals and their beliefs
from someone who worships Vishnu,
than say, a Protestant from
a Catholic in Christianity
or a Sunni from a Shia in Islam.
And what's fascinating about Hinduism
is that you don't see
these traditional schisms,
you don't see a lot of conflict
between the Shaivas or the Vaishnavas,
because to Hindus,
even though you have this
diversity of practice
across India or across
the Hindu tradition,
they're all viewed as aspects of Brahman.
They're all viewed as
different ways to visualize
or to connect with the fundamental reality
or the fundamental god.
And because Hinduism
has been able to merge
these very diverse practices,
these very diverse rituals,
and it's believed this emerged
because as Hinduism emerged,
it took traditions from the
Indus valley civilization.
It took significant traditions
from the Indo-Aryans.
from the Dravidians.
Instead of saying, "Hey
our different traditions
"are different religions,"
they merged over thousands
of years into one religion.
And the word for this merging,
taking an amalgamation
of multiple rituals,
multiple ideas, multiple,
multiple practices,
and turning them into one
is known as syncretism.
Hinduism is perhaps the
best example of syncretism
where you have these
incredibly diverse practices.
The gods that I show here
are just a sample of them,
but they've been connected
through this overarching,
very diverse religion called Hinduism.
And to a Hindu,
they're all ways of connecting
with the fundamental Brahman.
And to remind that,
we could just zoom out
and we see the connection with Brahman
which is viewed as this
fundamental reality.
Which raises an interesting question.
Hinduism is oftentimes cited
as a polytheistic religion.
Polytheism, you have multiple gods.
And clearly, I've cited multiple
gods even in this video,
and this is a sample of all
of the gods in Hinduism.
But at the same time,
they're all perceived
by many or most Hindus
as to being aspects or ways to connect
with the fundamental reality of Brahman
who many Hindus would call to
be the true fundamental God.
And so based on that they would say,
"These are just aspects of the one God."
And so they would argue
that it is monotheistic.
So I'll let you decide how you view it
or if it even matters to put apply a label
like monotheism or polytheism
to the idea of Hinduism.
The big picture is,
is that you have many
gods and many practices
and they are diverse
across the Hindu world,
but they are all viewed as connected
to this notion of a Brahman.